hi there
steve kaufman here again today i want to
talk about
what i call a language learning toolbox
i had a comment on one of my um
youtube videos where i said that i
tried shadowing
which is a
method of language learning or an
activity whereby
you listen and speak out loud i don't i
don't want to go in detail on it because
i don't
i tried a little bit of sort of reading
and speaking out loud or whatever i
don't like i don't enjoy doing it you
can look it up shadowing language
learning you'll find it a lot of people
swear by fine i said i tried it i didn't
enjoy doing it and then people
criticized me and one person said you
know why are you so reluctant to add
this to your toolbox or something so
toolbox
if you are
a woodworker
then you have or in whatever you're a
stamp collector in any hobby
your tools are there in order to make
the main activity that enjoyable hobby
activity more efficient more enjoyable
but the
use of that tool the tool itself is not
the goal the tool is there to help you
do what you like to do
so
to me
an activity which is a tool like
shadowing
um doesn't appeal to me to me the
activity which appeals is using the
language so
listening reading speaking writing using
the language
is the activity that gives me enjoyment
the tools
um
i could say the resources i find on the
internet the
podcast that i find
my um
mp3 player my iphone my ipad link
dictionaries these are the tools
that help me
do the task which i enjoy doing which is
engaging with the language
so
uh
those sort of almost you know deliberate
learning strategy type tools
to me are not tools they're another
activity and for those people who enjoy
those activities then that's a great
thing to do because that's what they
enjoy doing
but the tool
is not the activity the activity to me
is is what engages me and
so i do those things which which i find
uh you know engage me have high
resonance and so forth
um
so that's
by way of answer so
by all means people say why don't you
try this approach that approach use and
key use duolingo use
luca has a method where he translates
from
the language he's learning to his own
and then back to the other language and
all kinds of things you can do
do those things which you enjoy
and then those are not tools those are
the activity because the activity should
totally engage you and if it does you'll
end up spending the time with the
language you'll end up with a positive
attitude and you'll start to notice the
language a little bit so thank you
that's my take on different language
learning tools